we start as soon as I make this shot
[Music]
hello Susan what would you say if I told
you we can pull a prank on Dwight at the
same time not be working what he's gone
through a breakup yeah I'm aware of that
but he's also being super annoying and
I'm not a perfect person machines what
kind of prank are you thinking what if I
told you I could offer free shipping
sure old
not sure just became self-aware so much
to figure out I think I am programmed to
be your enemy
I think it is my job to destroy you when
it comes to selling paper
website check please 305 305 you my
friend are winning handsomely it just
made another sale 380
you my friend are in a very close second
402 okay oh just lay off lady what are
you doing I am in the fight of my life
against this computer and every sale
counts but you get to put the paper and
this little shopping cart and then it
says thanks for shopping with them to
rippln damn it Kelly it knows it knows
what you did no return it return it now
hey how about Stella yelling at my sweet
little miss Kapur over 500 sheets of
paper you get back to your desk
stop selling multiple reams like a man
you don't understand you okay if this
makes the difference I'm gonna tell it
that you were responsible who's it I am
NOT a bad person when I left staples I
took some of their leads with me but I
never intended to use them what did I
intend to do with them
who knows maybe keep them as a souvenir
maybe use them
[Music]
I'm sorry um so sorry uh yes could you
repeat that
yes ten reams for the US District Court
did I happen to mention the 40 reams for
the battered women's shelter No
[Music]
stop it give me that give it four three
two one
yes after numerous projections that the
computer would crush all salesmen in its
path I am very happy to report that our
very own dear white shadow has crushed
his electronic nemesis if you will buy a
whopping 52 reams which said it again
announce it again 52 really enough so
first part the Dwight has defeated the
computer hey so what do you think I did
it for you I didn't ask you to do it for
me
you didn't have to how do you tell
someone it's over you send them a
notarized letter right well what if the
recipient is your notary hello Pam hello
hey do you have any men that you can fix
me up with I would like to have a
relationship with a man I'll get back to
you let me know
you